bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat tout l'été je vous
propose de voir ou de revoir tous les
textes phar de la session parlementaire
avec un focus aujourd'hui sur la réforme
territoriale un texte essentiel pour le
Sénat au mois d'avril 2014 le tout
nouveau Premier ministre manuel Vals
avait annoncé lors de son discours de
politique générale cette réforme
territoriale il avait surtout annoncé la
disparition du département ce qui avait
suscité la colère des élus locaux la
colère des sénateurs qui d'une part
estimai que cette disparition n'était
pas souhaitable mais également avait
trouvé qu'il n'y avait eu aucune
concertation sur ce sujet alors au fil
des mois et bien le gouvernement avait
dû rétropédaler vous allez le voir le
ton avait extrêmement changé lorsqu'au
mois d'octobre et bien le Premier
ministre minist manuelétait à nouveau
revenu au Sénat cette fois-ci pour
annoncer que le département était bien
maintenu retour donc dans l'hémicycle
mesdames et messieurs les
ministres notre pays face à la
mondialisation au monde doit se réformer
pour relever les défis de la
compétitivité et de la
solidarité pour renforcer son
économie et moderniser sa puissance
publique réformer notre pays c'est bien
la mission que m'a confier le président
de la République mais on ne réforme
jamais seul réformer implique de
dialoguer
d'expliquer pour que les objectifs
soient partagés par tous en tout cas par
le plus grand nombre et il était
important pour
moi alors que reprennent aujourd'hui vos
travaux sur la réforme territoriale de
m'exprimer dans cet
hémicycle et je vous remercie monsieur
le président Gérard Larcher de cette
invitation
elle me permet de vous
exposer le sens de la réforme et sa
cohérence il y a plus de 30 ans
souvenons- en le président de la
République Fran fr mitan disait la
France a eu besoin d'un pouvoir fort et
centralisé pour se faire elle a
aujourd'hui besoin d'un pouvoir
décentralisé pour ne pas se défaire et
ces mots n'ont rien perdu de leur force
de leur pertinence la décentralisation
ce n'est pas qu'une démarche
administrative pas uniquement un
disposit
institionnel c'est un souffle un élan
pour l'unité de la République sa
cohésion et l'efficacité de son action
et pour être plus forte la République a
besoin de renforcer ces
territoires dès mon premier discours de
politique générale et ici devant vous
j'ai fait de la réforme
territoriale une priorité priorité pour
notre pays pour répondre à ses attentes
au défis qui se présent à lui le 3 juin
dernier dans sa tribune dans la presse
quotidienne régionale le président de la
République en a fixé les ambitions la
France d'aujourd'hui c'est un pays qui
en 30 ans a gagné 10 millions
d'habitants ce dynamisme démographique
est une force que nous devons prendre en
compte dans l'organisation dans dans
l'aménagement de notre territoire 3/4 de
la population se concentre sur 20 % de
l'espace le fait métropolitain n'est pas
un fantasme de géographe c'est la
réalité quotidienne de dizaines de
millions de Français la
franceaujourd'hui c'est un pays dont les
frontières anciennes entre ville et
campagne s'estompe chaque jour davantage
95 % de nos citoyens de nos concitoyens
vivent dans le territoires que l'on dit
sous influence urbaine mais ces aires
urbaines se diversifie se complexifie la
France d'aujourd'hui ce sont également
de nouvelles inégalités territoriales et
aussi des fractures parfois anciennes
qui se sont aggravé je parcours comme
vous notre pays j'en connais la beauté
et la diversité j'en perçois aussi les
angoisses les
détresses j'ai parlé à ces habitants des
zones au March des grandes villes qui
s'inquiète devant la disparition des
services publics la poste les classes
des écoles qui ferment la brigade de
gendarmerie qui est menacée j'ai échangé
aussi comme vous avec ces jeunes qui
doivent quitter leur village la petite
ville où ils sont nés où ils ont leurs
attaches parce qu'ils se disent ou parce
qu'on leur dit que leur avenir n'est
plus ici j'ai rencontré vous ces
ouvriers ces employés qui voient leur
usine fermé parce que l'outil de
production est restructuré délocalisé et
j'ai enfin dialogué avec ces
agriculteurs qui malgré leurs efforts
quotidiens doutent de la pérénité de
leur exploitation tous ces témoignages
parmi bien d'autres viennent souligner
ce risque croissant d'une dualité du
territoire national dualité avec d'un
côté les grandes vill les métropoles
inséré dans la mondialisation qui
connaissent un vrai dynamisme économique
et il ne faut pas le nier même plutôt
sans féliciter pour en saisir toutes les
opportunités qui doivent profiter à tous
le législateur en a tiré les
conséquences d'ailleurs en 2013 en
consacrant le rôle des métropoles en
affirmant aussi la solidarité qui devait
exist entre elles et leur périphérie la
dualité c'est à l'opposé des métropoles
des territoires qui se sentent à l'écart
et subissent de plein fouet les effets
de la mondialisation les conséquen de la
crise économique et sociale ces
territoires sont fragilisés ils pensent
être oubliés abandonné par la puissance
publique ils ont le sentiment que le
lien qui les unit à la République
s'effrite jour après jour ce qui remit
en cause c'est la promesse républicaine
offrir les mêmes opportunités que que
l'on vive au cœur d'une métropole en
banlieu dans une commune périurbaine en
montagne ou dans les autres mers ces
fractures territoriales ce sont aussi
des fractures scolaires elles se sont
accrues ces 15 dernières années les
difficultés scolaires se concentrent
dans certains établissements dans les
quartiers défavorisés mais aussi dans
les territoires ruraux et nous avons
donc décid depuis cette rentrée de
relancer l'éducation prioritaire et je
salue en passant
l'expérimentation en cours dans les
départements du Cantal et des Hautes
Pyrénées les élus locaux et les services
de l'éducation national innve pour
réorganiser le maillage scolaire avec
les moyens dégagés il développe des
dispositifs pédagogiques comme l'accueil
des moins de 3 ans ou le plus de maîtres
que de classe c'est là aussi un bel
exemple d'intelligence collective et de
pragmatisme mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs toutes ces fractures vous les
connaissez
aussi bien que moi mais apporter des
réponses adaptées nécessite une analyse
fine une analyse approfondie c'est le
premier objectif des Assises des
ruralités engagé avec la ministre du
Logement de l'égalité des territoires et
de le ralité sylvia Pinel il n'y aurait
en effet rien de pire que des réponses
identi à des situations si diverses la
réforme de l'État territorial qui est
tout aussi fondamental et complémentaire
engagé par le ministre de l'Intérieur
Bernard casenu poursuit aussi cet
objectif un état plus réactif qui
s'adapte aux besoins des territoires et
aux attentes des élus locaux nous devons
réaffirmer la présence et le rôle de
l'État notamment dans les départements
là où les citoyens en ont le plus besoin
dans un monde qui bouge si vite
l'immobilisme le statut quo l'absence de
courage pour notre pays des choix lourds
de conséquence des territoires sans
moyens pour construire leur avenir des
élus locaux démunis face aux attentes de
nos concitoyens pierre morroi qui a
tellement compté pour la
décentralisation avait vu juste aucune
organisation politique ne peut
s'abstraire des conditions de son époque
et le cadre dans lequel la France évolue
a été profondément bouleversé
accélération de la mondialisation
élargissement de l'Union européenne
mobilité croissante des Français de
nouveaux équilibres mais aussi de
nouveau déséquilibres se dégage et
soyons lucide notre organisation
territoriale actuelle peine à faire face
à tout cela elle doit donc évoluer le
premier objectif de cette réforme c'est
de renforcer tous les territoire de
doter les plus dynamiques des
compétences nécessaires pour poursuivre
leur développement économique mais tout
en veillant à ce que les territoires
fragilisés ne soient ni abandonnés à
leur sort ni privés de chance de
développement et le second objectif
c'est de redonner du sens à une action
publique devenue souvent illisible et
les doublons concerne aussi l'action de
l'État et des collectivités locales oui
la clarification et l'objectif monsieur
le Président retillot clarté
efficacité baisse de la dépense publique
é clarté efficacité baisse de la dépense
publique proximité voilà ce que nos
concitoyens attendent de leurs
institutions sortons des caricatures
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu lire ou
entendre cette réforme n'a pas pour but
d'affaiblir les pouvoirs locaux ni
remettre en cause l'action des élus au
contraire elle est une preuve de
confiance renouvelé dans le d'agir pour
l'intérêt général et le renforcement de
l'efficacité de nos services publics
cette confiance fait l'objet d'un
consensus national en 1982 et en 1983 il
n'existait pas mais aujourd'hui il fait
l'objet d'un consensus national cela a
été porté par Gaston de fer pierre Jox
Jean-Pierre cheved une confiance qui
grâce au président jacquesirac et à son
premier ministre
jeanpierrearin figure désormais dans
notre Constitution la République est
désormais décentralisée au même titre
qu'elle est laïque indivisible
démocratique et social on peut regretter
d'ailleurs que depuis 2007 aucune
avancée n'a eu lieu en matière de
décentralisation et en effet le projet
de conseiller territorial n'en était pas
une il n'apportait aucune réponse réel
et utile aux enjeux de nos
territoires la décentralisation
c'est donc un fondement de la France et
le renforcement de sa
démocratie depuis 30 ans les politiques
menées par les communes les départements
les régions ont façonné nos paysage
moderniser les modes de transport et les
équipements elles ont renforcé la
solidarité facilité l'accès du plus
grand nombre à la culture au sport à
l'éducation et plus récemment au
numérique plus encore
la décentralisation a permis
d'approfondir nos démocrati local de
renforcer le lien de proximité de
confiance qui doit exister entre les
citoyens et leurs représentants ce
mouvement doit bien sûr se poursuivre
c'est le sens des textes sur le N cumule
et nous avons eu ici même de beaux
débats mais c'est là une évolution
majeure de nos pratiques politiques et
une attente forte des Français qui
veulent des élus se consacrant
pleinement à leur mandat c'est le sens
également des avancées en matière de
parité que j'ai porté devant vous mais
d'ors et déjà soyons conscient de tout
ce qui a été accompli soyons conscients
des évolutions que nous avons su mener
ensemble et soyons certains mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qu'aucun retour
en arrière sur ces deux sujets non
cumule et parité ne sera possible c'est
ma conviction et j'en suis convaincu
elle est partagée par le plus grand
nombre la France
la France je le rappelais est une et
indivisible mais la vision d'une France
uniforme avec des territoires identiques
et dépassé la carte administrative de la
France doit donc tenir compte des
spécificités locales et c'est du bon
sens un territoire rural par exemple ne
fait face ni aux mêmes réalités ni au
même défi qu'une métropole c'est
pourquoi je me suis engagé auprès des
élus de montagne des élus des
territoires ruraux j'y reviendrai à
adapter la réforme territoriale aux
spécificités de leur territoire et je
veux que nous soyons pragmatiques et que
nous fassions confiance aux acteurs
locaux mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs une
France qui change nécessite que notre
organisation territoriale évolue les
états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale monsieur le Président par
votre prédécesseur sur une belle
initiative pour lancer un mouvement
mais
reconnaissons-le face aux attentes
multiples parfois contradictoir nous
avons trop longtemps hésité quant à la
direction que nous devions prendre puis
finalement nous avons fait le choix de
commencer par les mopole madame la
ministre texte porté par votre collègue
van donc au 1er janvier 10 métropoles
seront créées à Lyon Bordeaux Toulouse
Nantes Brest Lille rouan Grenoble
Strasbourg et Montpellier et Nice
existait déjà elles auront des
compétences accrues en matière
d'aménagement d'innovation et de
développement économique mais ell
devront aussi forcer les solidarités et
en créer de nouvelles le rôle de nos
métropoes sera pleinement atteint si
elle réussiss à concilier rayonnement
sur le plan européen sur le plan mondial
proximité et cohésion sociale sur leur
territoire s'agissant du Grand Paris il
était essentiel que la région capitale
franchisse une nouvelle étape dès 2016
l'émergence de la métropole et le
renforcement des intercommunalités en
grande couronne
permettront de renforcer c'est un
élément essentiel pour notre pays
l'attractivité et le rayonnement
international le Grand Paris c'est une
grande ambition pour la France et la
métropole parisienne doit donc disposer
d'un véritable projet global le
gouvernement y travaille avec les élus
locaux les élus locaux avancent
eux-mêmes et dans le consensus et c'est
une bonne chose nous devons adapter le
dispositif législatif aux enjeux de la
première métropole française j'y suis
favorable et je l'ai dit à la
modification de l'article 12 de la loi
mappan tant que la simplification
institutionnelle et la solidarité
territoriale demeure l'objectif mais je
n'ai pas de doute sur le fait que nous
puissions atteindre ce but la métropole
Dex marseille- provovence doit également
voir le jour en 2016 la construction de
cette grande métropole du sud de cette
porte ouverte vers la Méditerranée est
un enjeu essentiel et le gouvernement
dialogue avec tous les élus nous vous
écoutons et nous écoutons notamment le
sénateur maire Jean-Claude Godin pour
construire le cadre institutionnel adapt
et bâtir un projet urbain de qualité je
sais combien les habitants l'attendent
et je sais combien notre responsabilité
collective c'est d'aider et de soutenir
la deè ville de France je veux enfin
saluer le travail exemplaire men par le
Conseil Général du rô et la future
métropole de Lyon sous l'impulsion de
vos collègues Gérard Colomb et Michel
Mercier la création de cette métropole
doit permettre des simplifications dès
le 1er janvier 2015 et des synergies
importante en particulier en matière
d'aménagement de logement et de
politique sociale après les métropole
l'étape engagée depuis avril doit
permettre de renforcer les régions en
faisant notamment émergé de façon
harmonieuse le couple région métropole
et de clarifier les compétences des
différents niveaux de collectivité votre
assemblée examinera dès aujourd'hui ce
soir en deuxème lecture le projet de loi
sur la carte des régions il a été voté
cela n'aura échappé à personne par une
large majorité et ce dès la première
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale cette
nouvelle carte
semblait pour beaucoup impossible à
tracer beaucoup y ont renoncé par le
passé et bien dans quelques semaines
elle sera une réalité comme nous en
sommes convenus monsieur le Président le
projet de loi sur les compétences sera
débattu à partir du mois de décembre il
sera présenté par la ministre de la
décentralisation madame Lebranchu et le
secrétaire d'État à la réforme
territoriale monsieur Vallini la
nouvelle organisation territoriale ce
sont tout d'abord des territoires plus
forts capables de préparer l'avenir et
c'est la mission des région qui devront
bénéficier de levier puissant de
levierers stratégiqu pour préparer leur
avenir et celui de notre pays l'avenir
en matière
d'éducation de formation professionnelle
et d'orientation au service de notre
jeunesse l'avenir en matière de
transport et de mobilité c'est essentiel
pour la promotion d'un modèle le
développement orienté vers la transition
énergétique et écologique l'avenir aussi
en matière d'aménagement du territoire
les régions doivent devenir les garants
d'un développement équilibré et de la
redistribution des richesses appartenir
à des régions fortes ce sera ainsi une
chance en tout cas c'est leur défi pour
les territoires les plus fragiles
l'avenir enfin bien sûr en matière de
développement économique et
d'accompagnement des entreprises je suis
favorable à de nouveaux transferts de
compétences de l'État vers les régions
en matière de développement économique
et à l'expérimentation en matière
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi la revue
des missions de l'État engagé par
Bernard casenuve et Thierry Mandon doit
nous y aider la réorganisation de toutes
les compétences que je viens d'évoquer
instaure donc aussi une nouvelle
relation entre l'État et les régions et
je l'ai souligné au Congrès des régions
de France elle crée la nécessité d'un
permanent sur les grandes stratégies
économiques et d'aménagement du
territoire et pour bâtir ensemble cette
nouvelle relation j'ai proposer que le
gouvernement et l'ensemble des
présidents de région se réunissent
régulièrement des régions regroupées
c'est aussi un territoire national plus
équilibré la commission spéciale du
Sénat a proposé une nouvelle carte des
régions et je me réjouis que les
sénateurs se saisissent pleinement de ce
texte j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
au président Larcher le gouvernement
sera très attentif à l'évolution des
débats ils sont parfois vif je pense par
exemple à celui sur l'avenir de l'Alsace
dont nous connaissons tous et dont je
connais la place dans notre histoire
nationale et dans la République j'ai
reçu encore il y a quelques jours les
parlementaires ainsi que les présidents
de la région et de deux Conseils
généraux mais nous avons besoin de
clarté et à mon sens la carte votée à
l'Assemblée nationale a ce mérite je
vous laisse bien sûr en débattre mais en
tout état de cause 12 régions
hexagonales c'est le but que nous nous
sommes donné quel changement et quelle
réforme et à tous ceux qui disent que
cette réforme territoriale n'apporte pas
un changement je leur demande de
regarder en face en combien de temps
nous avons réussi cette réforme et quels
sont les changements ette nelle carte de
région apportera à notre pays
assurer le développement de notre pays
c'est renforcer l'efficacité de l'action
publique c'est aussi veiller à sa
proximité c'est renforcer un second
couple commune intercommunalité les
politiques publiques que ce soit en
matière de politique sociale de vie
quotidienne
de culture de sport doivent être
élaborés au plus près des citoyens ceux
d'entre nous qui ont été maires ou élu
local savent combien les Français sont
attachés à leur commune à cette
institution du quotidien mais aussi à
leurs élus le maire le maire c'est bien
souvent le seul visage de la République
dans une petite commune et le maire
c'est souvent le seul responsable public
dans lequel beaucoup de nos concitoyens
se reconnaissent les conseillers
municipaux et aujourd'hui les
conseillers communautaires ce sont des
milliers de femmes et d'hommes engagés
et généreux pourquoi s'interrompre quand
on parle des maires bénévoolle ou quasi
bénévole pour la plupart qui constitue
le socle de notre vie politique et
puisque nous l'avons évoqué il y a un
instant à l'occasion des obsèques de
Christian Bourquin à mias dans son pays
catalan j'avais eu l'occasion de
rappeler devant une foule nombreuse
combien ses élus et notamment ses maires
devaient davantage respecté par leurs
concitoyens tant ils donnaient à leurs
citoyens c'est aussi cela la charpente
institutionnelle de notre pays elle
évolue et le fait dans le dialogue les
propositions de loi portées par les
députés Jacques Pélissard président de
la MF et Christine pires bon un
parlementaire de l'opposition une
parlementaire de la majorité sur les
communes nouvelles elles ont je le sais
votre soutien monsieur le sénateur
françois Barouin vise à rendre les
communes plus fortes et elles seront
examinées à l'Assemblée nationale cette
semaine et je l'espère rapidement au
Sénat des communes plus fortes ce sont
aussi des communes qui savent travailler
ensemble conruire une intercommunalité
nous l'avons fait j'étaéis président
d'une intercommunalité qui s'est élargie
c'est donc une chance pour mieux gérer
pour mutualiser pour créer des projets
de territoire en somme pourvoir plus
grande ensemble l'intercommunalité c'est
aussi ce lieu où bien souvent l'intérêt
général prime où les élus dépassent
leséclivage locaux ou partisans et les
mêmes qui s'invectivent et qui
s'interrompent dans un débat au Sénat et
à l'assemblée sont les mêmes qui dans
dans leur intercommunalité votent
ensemble des projets pour l'intérêt
général et c'est cette France qui s'est
travaillé pour l'intérêt général qui est
attendu par les Français et non pas dans
des hémicycles où on
s'invective nous devons approfondir le
processus intercommunal et je suis sûr
que nous pouvons tous nous mettre
d'accord là-dessus et penser les
politiques à l'échelle des bassin de vie
et cela sur tout le territoire dans de
nombreux endroits le seul 20000
habitants apparaîtra de fait comme un
minimum et
sera dans de nombreux endroits le seuil
de 20000 habitants apparaîtra de fait
comme un minimum et sera largement
dépasser dans d'autres dans d'autres je
l'ai dit dans d'autres je l'ai dit
écoutez il faudra
l'adapter écoutez-moi et tenir compte du
nombre de communes a de la densité de la
topographie il ne sert à rien de
m'interrompre d'autant plus que je vais
vous surprendre et je l'ai indiqué je
l'ai indiqué et je suis sûr que même
parmi ceux qui crient qui cherchent à
m'interrompre ils l'ont approuvé et
applaudi je l'ai indiqué à la convention
de l'intercommunalité à Lille et devant
les élus de montagne à Chambéry nous
pourrions donner aux commissions
départemental et au préfet de
département un pouvoir de modulation du
seuil et moi je serais
je serai attentif aux propositions du
Sénat sur les dérogations apportées
monsieurs et mesadames les sénateurs les
périmètres des intercommunalités doivent
se rapprocher des espaces vécus c'est le
moyen le plus efficace de permettre un
égal accès aux services publics locaux
et dans un contexte de vigilance quant à
la dépense publique que vous nous
rappelez ce développement des EPCI
mettra fin au vrais millefeuill
territoriales dont on ne parle pas assez
celui des 13400 syndicats intercommunaux
et ces syndicats je vous le rappelle ce
sont 17 milliards d'euros de budget dont
9 en fonctionnement dans un souci
d'économie leur nombre devra être
fortement réduit comme nous y incite le
rapport de Monsieur Alain Lambert et
Martin Malvi leurs compétences devront
aussi évidemment estre transféré aux
intercommunalités et je partage
l'attachement du président Didier
Guillaume à cette dynamique avec
l'élection des conseillers
communautaires par fléchage le même jour
et par le même vote que les conseillers
municipaux l'intercommunalité a enfin
trouvé progressivement la légitimité
démocratique qui lui manquait cette
démocratie intercommunale nous devrons
sans doute encore l'approfondir mais il
faut sur ces questions
temp nous devrons aussi toujours garder
à l'esprit que la gouvernance
intercommunale pour être efficace doit
reposer sur l'accord de chacun et je
sais que c'est l'objectif de la
proposition de loi de vos collègues
Jean-Pierre suur et Alain Richard vous
l'avez adopté la semaine dernière ce
texte doit aboutir rapidement et sera
donc inscrit à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale avant la fin de
l'année comme je m'y étais engagé entre
de grandes régions stratèges et le
couple commune intercommunalité il faut
des échelons intermédiaires pour assurer
les solidarités social et
territorial j'ai conscience et je n
cessa de le
dire encore vendredi à la délégation de
président de conseils généraux que j'ai
reçu à Matignon et je me rendrai au
congrès de l'Association des
départements de France à poau dans
quelques jours le rô rôle des conseils
départementaux en matière de protection
des populations les plus fragiles et de
soutien aux communes est bien sûr
indispensable j'ai écouté les
parlementaires les associations d'élus
et les élus des départements les
formations politiques aussi et vous
connaissez le dialogue que j'ai eu avec
Jean-Michel baayet les Radicaux de
Gauche chers Jacques mzard les
assemblées
départementales les assemblées
départementales qui seront désignées
lors des élections des 22 et 29 mars
prochains exerceront
pleinement leurs compétences de
solidarité si importante pour nos
concitoyens et je veux saluer à ce titre
l'engagement des personnels des
département lors de cette phase de
transition je veux être très clair la
collectivité départementale pourra même
être conforté sur ses compétences de
solidarité territoriale et humaine par
par exemple en matière d'ingénierie
territoriale et d'accès aux services au
public après 2020 le paysage territorial
aura évolué les régions se seront
approprié leurs nouvelles compétences
les intercommunalités structureront plus
encore qu'aujourd'hui les territoires
alors peut-être le cadre départemental
pourra évoluer là où il y a des
métropoles je vous ai lu c'est évident
et je note qu'il y a consensus sur ce
point d'autres initiatives d'autres
initiatives bienvenue cher Didier
Guillaume mais il y en a d'autres dans
cette assemblée voit le jour avec des
rapprochements en cours entre conseils
départementaux ou une meilleure
coordination des
intercommunalités c'est un mouvement de
réforme que le gouvernement entend
construire avec les territoires pour
permettre à chacun de trouver la force
forme d'organisation qui leur convient
le mieux et cela prend nécessairement du
temps l'histoire de la construction
intercommunale au fond très récente le
montre bien nous avons donc 5 ans pour
préparer sereinement les évolutions pour
donner aux élus de nouvelles
opportunités d'adapter les organisations
à la diversité des des situations
faisons confiance aux initiatives
locales et je compte moi sur le
Parlement et en tout cas sur le Sénat
sur ce sujet-là pour faire avancer les
choses mesdames messieurs la grandeur de
la France c'est la grandeur des
territoire il y a bien sûr la question
des institutions je viens de l'aborder
il y a également la question des moyens
là aussi j'entends vos interrogations
vos remarques aussi je tiens à le redire
l'effort de redressement de nos comptes
public incombe à tous et les
collectivités devront et doivent y
prendre leur part cependant cette
politique de sérieux budgétaire nous
devons la mener en maintenant nos
priorités et parmi ces priorités il y a
bien sûr l'investissement des
propositions ont été formulées par les
députés dans le cadre du projet loi de
finance je pense par exemple à la hausse
du taux du fond de compensation de la
TVA l'investissement local c'est aussi
la contractualisation avec les
territoires et je sais que vous êtes
toutes et tous vigilant aux discussions
en cours sur les contrats de plan ils
mobiliseront 12 milliards d'euros pour
les transports l'enseignement supérieur
et la recherche et la transition
énergétique et pour que les régions
disposent des capacités à investir elles
devront être doté d'une fiscalité
économique dynamique et adapté à leur
mission les capacités financières des
territoires c'est aussi l'effort de
péréquation nous avons décidé de le
poursuivre la réforme de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement devra
rapprocher les moyens du monde rural
avec ceux des territoires urbains et je
proposerai de confier à deux
parlementaires l'un de la majorité
l'autre de l'opposition une mission sur
ce sujet-là les moyens des territoires
enfin ce sont ceux pour l'école les
maires dans leur immense majorité se
sont mobilisés pour la réussite de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires
et grâce à eux grâce à eux et je veux
les en remercier
de nouvelles activités sont offertes aux
enfants des parlementaires de tous les
bancs des parlementaires de tous les
bancs des élus locaux et leurs
associations ont demandé que le soutien
apportés aux communes soit poursuivi
pour des accueils périscolaires de
qualité les amendements ont été déposés
ce matin à l'Assemblée nationale par les
groupes CRC et RDP le gouvernement avec
la ministre de l'Éducation nationale les
soutiendra le fond d'amorçage pour les
rythmes scolaires sera donc maintenu à
son niveau
actuel les
parlementaires proposent d'ajouter qu'un
projet éducatif territorial s'assure de
la de la qualité des activités mais ce
dispositif devra être mis en œuvre avec
souplesse en tenant compte des
situations locales et les services de
l'État seront mobilisés
pour accompagner les communes et comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de l'indiquer ici
même dans cette hémicycle au ministre
françois Barouin je reste à la
disposition des maires de France pour
avancer sur la question et des finances
locales et du financement de cette
réforme concernant les rythmes scolaires
mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs cette réforme
territoriale marquera une étape le
dynamisme de nos communes
de nos
intercommunalités de nos départements de
nos régions doit bénéficier d'un cadre
renouvelé nous le savons bien et les
Français qui soutiennent largement cette
réforme le savent aussi aussi je
souhaiterais conclure sur la méthode et
si vous me le permettez sur le rôle du
Sénat en partant de la Constitution le
Sénat examine en premier les projets
relatifs au é locale mais sur ces sujets
aussi c'est l'Assemblée nationale qui a
le dernier mot si
chacun joue son rôle si chacun joue son
rôle Sénat assemblée national et
gouvernement nous pouvons faire de cet
équilibre une chance pour la réforme et
non pas un affrontement moi je tiens
compte de ce que les élus locaux disent
je tiendrai
compte je tiendrai compte je tiendrai
compte de ce que le Sénat dira et je
suis sûr que chacun doit tenir compte de
la force de sa propre majorité à
l'Assemblée comme au Sénat et l'état
d'esprit qui est le mien doit être
l'état d'esprit pour y arriver de chacun
lors de la première lecture du projet
loi sur les régions une majorité a
choisi de ne pas rentrer dans le fond du
du texte elle était de circonstances et
de ne pas formuler de vraies
propositions l'Assemblée nationale elle
s'est saisie du projet du gouvernement
et l'a amendé de manière significative
aujourd'hui la deuxième lecture offre au
Sénat la possibilité de jouer pleinement
son rôle de législateur et vous savez
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs que le gouvernement veut
croire dans ce dialogue nous ne serons
pas d'accord sur tout mais toutes vos
propositions seront examin et je sais
que vous avez la possibilité de faire
bouger les lignes dans l'intérêt de la
décentralisation dans l'intérêt des
collectivité locale et dans l'intérêt
des Français ce que nous sommes capables
de faire ensemble les uns et les autres
je le disais en particulier dans nos
intercommunalités pour promouvoir et
développer nos territoires je suis
certain que le Sénat l'Assemblée
nationale et le gouvernement donc
peuvent le faire pour aboutir à une
réforme juste et efficace et
intelligente ai-je besoin de rappeler
que les débats que nous avons ou que
nous allons reprendre traverse toutes
nos formations politiques et chacun a en
tête les débats et les étapes de tous
les grands textes de décentralisation
depuis
1982 il y a ici des visages familiers
qui s'pposaient avec la plus grande
virilance aux grandes lois de
décentralisation de François mitteran de
Pierre MAOI et de Gaston de fer et qui
aujourd'hui en sont les plus ardents
défenseurs donnons-nous rendez-vous dans
quelques années sur ces textes et chacun
sait que tout ce qui a
tenu tout ce qui a perduré et c'est
considérable le doigt à une raison la
réponse à l'intérêt général c'est dans
cette voie et uniquement dans cette voix
que je veux m'inscrire pardà les
convictions par-delà les itinéraires
par-dà les oppositions je doute pas que
vous serez animé par un esprit de
responsabilité et par un amour partagé
de notre pays alors
avançons
proposons réformons et moi sur les
régions sur
l'intercommunalité sur les départements
sur les
compétences je suis convaincu que nous
pouvons le faire et donc je veux faire
avec vous le Paris de la confiance et ce
Paris si nous sommes tous à la hauteur
de nos responsabilités nous pouvons le
gagner merci
monsieur le Premier
ministre dans la suite de notre débat la
parole est maintenant aux orateurs des
groupes le premier orateur inscrit est
le président Jacques mzzard vous avez la
parole monsieur le
président
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier
Ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues monsieur
le Premier ministre je tiens en premier
lieu à vous remercier au nom de mon
groupe d'avoir participé à l'éloge que
vient de rendre le Sénat à notre
regretté collègue et ami Christian
Bourquin
le plus bel hommage que nous pouvons
rendre au président
Bourquin c'est en se souvenant du combat
qu'il a encore mené ici même en juillet
lors des questions d'actualité et dans
sa chère région de voter le rejet de la
fusion avec midi
piréné tout ce qu'il a exprimé avec tant
de convictions et tant d'arguments
économique géographique historique nous
le partageons nous savons que
Montpellier et Toulouse sont deux
capitales régionales construites au
cours de nombreux siècles avec beaucoup
de souffrance mais aussi d'expérience et
que l'une ne saurait effacer l'autre
monsieur le Premier ministre le Sénat a
entendu le message du président Bourquin
dans sa réunion de la commission
spéciale il y a quelques jours et aussi
le message de la quasi unanimité de son
conseil régional il vous appartient
d'entendre le message du Sénat et de
rester aurit le langdoc Rousillon dans
sa plénitude mais et j'ai bien entendu
votre discours avec intérêt vous nous
avez dit qu'il fallait que nous
travailons ensemble pour améliorer ce
texte je regrette quand même qu'il y ait
quelques minutes le gouvernement et
déposé un amendement que j'ai
ici pour revenir strictement à la carte
des régions voté par la l'Assemblée
nationale cela limite cela limite quand
même
considérablement la possibilité de
dialogue et de
débat réformé il n'est de gouvernement
ou de candidat à la gouvernance qui
nuse etabus de ce mot dont le
dictionnaire mes chers collègues donne
une définition que nous pourrions
méditer réformer je cite rétablir dans
sa forme primitive une règle qui s'est
corrompue
en fait les mutations technologiques
sociologiques économiques que nos
sociétés connaissent ces dernières
décennies imposent des évolutions
législatives plus rapides dans nombre de
domaines nous en sommes les premiers
convaincus de là à modifier
l'architecture des collectivités locales
et les systèmes électoraux après chaque
alternance donc tous les 5 ans il y a un
faussé
pour nous une réforme n'a de sens que si
elle améliore la situation
existante est-ce le cas de la réforme
territoriale que vous nous
proposez nous ne le croyons pas et
chaque semaine qui passe nous confirme
dans cette appréciation manifestement
les gouvernements successifs ne font pas
confiance à l'intelligence
territoriale le rapport Belot ne
prévoyait aucunement le conseiller
territorial le rapport ctinger ne
pouvait sérieusement être le précurseur
des deux projets de loi validés le 19
juin dernier par le Conseil des
ministres depuis 2 ans et plus
d'ailleurs quel sal migandi de texte mal
préparé parfois contradictoire l'exemple
malheureux du rétablissement de la
clause générale de compétence puis de sa
suppression n'était qu'une
péripétie d'un ensemble personne n
surtout pas un élu local n'y trouve
cohérence ni vision d'ensemble un jour
blanc un jour noir pour une réforme tout
en gris un chemin chaotique vers des
lendemains
instables je n'ai strictement rien à
retrancher à ce que je disais à cette
même tribune le 3 juillet dernier nous
avions raison de considérer que ce
projet de loi ne reposait pas sur une
véritable étude
d'impact le produit d'aucune
concertation d'aucune consultation des
collectivités régionales concernées dont
plusieurs se sont néanmoins exprimé très
fortement en opposition bien que très
majoritairement dirigé par vos
proches comment comprendre la finalité
réelle de ces projets quand on les
compare et je l'ai fait dans les mois
passés au discours du président de la
République avant et après son élection
et j'y étais
à vos déclarations ici même monsieur le
Premier ministre lorsque vous étiez
ministre de l'Intérieur et que vous
défendiez devant nous le projet binô je
vous
cite certains continuent de croire que
moderniser la vie politique local c'est
supprimé un
échelon un peu plus loin le département
est un échelon de proximité essentiel un
échelon républicain par excellence je
continue onéliore pas l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en éloignant les
citoyens des
décisions
commener commenceer par découper des
régions avant de parler des compétences
des collectivités et de leurs
ressources c'est surréaliste et pourtant
c'est ce qui se passe mais je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse impunément découper les
régions comme la France découper ses
colonies sur la base des égau de grands
élus selon l'arbitraire de
l'exécutif petite région au nord grande
région au sud faut-il mes chers
collègues pour l'exemple rappeler les
déclarations du maire de Thul indiquant
lors de sa campagne sénatoriale comment
il avait obtenu du président de la
République le changement de région du
Limousin vers
Laquitaine le maire de Thul peut obtenir
le changement de région pas le président
de l'agglomération d'oriac je comprends
bien je vous ferai grâce des
déclarations sur le terrain de nombre de
nos
collègues candidats aux élections
sénatoriales adept toujours du cumul des
mandats et destracteur de votre réforme
territoriale dans le Limousin par
exemple c'est exemplaire mais vérité sur
le terrain n'est pas forcément vérité à
Paris une carte
régionale déconnectée des grands bassins
de des flux économiques démographiques
ce peut-être et cela commence le retour
des iréantismes régionaux au mépris de
la construction de la nation et
l'aggravation des inégalités
territoriales nous avons été nombreux
dans cet hémicycle à partager les
conclusions du rapport rafarin kratinger
qui n'ont que peu de choses en commun
avec les deux projets de loi ce qu'
d'ailleurs confirmé avec force
notre ancien collègue ctinger en juillet
à la commission spéciale ce rapport
rafarin ctinger en 10 axes c'est
redessiner la carte des régions en 8 à
10 régions avec des compétences
stratégiques un nouvel avenir au
département avec un espace adapté à
l'expression démocratique de la ruralité
espace fédérateur des intercommunalités
la garantie de la présence de l'État
avec une répartition plus claire des
compétences ettat collectivité un schéma
obligatoire d'accessibilité au services
publics des territoires notamment les
plus enclavés on est loin de ces
objectifs on pouvait penser que ce
projet de loi avait pour but de trouver
les économies nécessaires au respect des
critères imposés par l'Europe monsieur
le secrétaire d'État avait annoncé
rapidement de très grandes
économies aujourd'hui on nous dit
qu'elles viendront dans un avenir
indéterminé en plus vous le savez bien
le meilleur moyen de pousser les
collectivités à des économies de gestion
c'est de couper leurt
en leur supprimant en 2017 6 % de leur
recettes c'est la réalité je ne je ne
dis pas que c'est
mal notre désaccord porte autant sur la
méthode que sur le fond et c'est
d'autant plus regrettable qu'il existe
une grande majorité d'élus pour
moderniser l'organisation territoriale
autour de grands
thème simplification et clarification
des compétences nous sommes d'accord
avec la suppression de la clause
générale de compéten nous sommes
d'accord développement de
l'intercommunalité avec contrainte et
bonification financière lorsqu'il y a
mutualisation bonification pour la
création de communes nouvelles voilà
l'avenir diminution et suppression de
nombre de structures interstitielles les
pays on peut les supprimer beaucoup de
syndicats mixtes d'agences d'association
parap publique et Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la diminution des normes
insupportable pour les collectivités
vous l'avez souvent dit à juste titre
mais il ne suffit pas de le dire il faut
le faire et il y a encore de
contreexemples nouvelles obligations de
la loi allure dans le domaine de la
création des scottes c'est une réalité
les maires n'en peuvent plus et nous
l'avons vécu lors de ces sénatoriales de
recevoir sans fin des courriers de
l'État leur imposant constamment de
nouvelles contraintes alors qu'ils ont
d'abord besoin d'assistance à leur
mission
un mot un mot sur les territoires dis
ruraux expression ambigu car il est des
territoires ruraux riches et d'autres
fragiles de par leur éloignement des
centres de décision des pôles
économiques de par leur démographie
déclinante et vieillissante ces projets
de loi je le pense peut-être que je me
trompe monsieur le Premier ministre mais
je crois que ces projets de loi vont
accenter ce déséquilibre territorial et
cette fracture comment voulez-vous que
ces territoires soi entendus dans de
grandes régions alors que pour certains
ils n'auront que deux conseillers
régionaux sur 150 ou 208 vous vous
retranchez derrière la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnel à tort comme
vous l'avez fait pour le binome c'est en
tout cas un traitement injuste que vous
infligez à ces territoires et ce ne sont
pas les assises de la ruralité qui
changeront le problème
faire des états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale ou des Assises
de la ruralité c'est aussi productif que
d'enterrer les problèmes en créant des
Commission en
outre en outre c'est baffouer
l'expression de sensibilité politique
diverse pourtant consacré par le texte
même de la
Constitution pour certains territoire
comme celui que je représente nous
allons vivre non une fusion mais ch èg
mais une
annexion d'autant plus insupportable que
la voix de nos deux représentants sera
étouffée au mépris de notre histoire de
la géographie de la proximité j'aurai le
privilège de représenter le département
le plus enclavé de France tant par
rapport à Paris qu'à la future métropole
régionale à 11h de train et 9h de route
aller-retour de tout
cela je ne saurais vous remercier et ne
puis que vous adresser du haut de cette
tribune une protestation
solennelle ce texte est mortifère pour
le territoire qui est le mien et la
sensibilité politique à laquelle je suis
profondément lié Monsieur le Premier
Ministre j'ai respect et estime pour
vous vous le savez mais pour tout cela
je continuerai à combattre votre projet
de
loi
côté économie permettez-moi de vous dire
que nous sommes dans l'illusionnisme car
aucune étude d'impact ne vient démontrer
que les textes que vous présentez
conduiront à des
économies alors comment esquiver ces
réformes une fois de plus et bien vous
nous proposez cette faus cette fausse
réforme structurelle qui consiste à
faire un redécoupage des régions on fait
croire aux Français qu'en divisant par
deux le nombre des hôtels de Région en
diminuant le nombre supposé coûteux des
élus on réalisera des économies
spectaculaires c'est vrai qu'avec une
carte facile à reproduire dans les
journaux on fait semblant de réformer
tandis qu'on laisse sous le tapis les
vrais défis qui gênent et quit a abusé
les esprits vous n'avez pas craint
d'être en plus dans l'incohérence c'est
cette stupéfiante façon de découper la
réforme en deux textes avec tout d'abord
le contenant et ensuite le contenu alors
peut-être que les experts en
communication ont mesuré qu'il était
plus facile de vendre une jolie carte en
couleur que de fastidieux transferts de
compéten mais je vous dis que en donnant
l'illusion du mouvement en commençant
par ce qu'il y a de plus à guichant nous
passons à côté de la vraie
réforme nous centristes nous sommes
convaincu qu'un minimum de rationalité
ne nuit pas à l'action publique
redécouper les régions avant de décider
ce qu'elles devront faire est un non
sens votre
démarche votre
démarche serait celle d'un architecte
qui commencera à construire un bâtiment
sans savoir ce que ses clients veulent
en faire avouez que les risques de
déboire sont élevés et ce faisant vous
nous placez vous l'avez d'ailleurs dit
tout à l'heure dans une alternative
pénible je le dis devant mes collègues
en effet soit nous nous rebellons contre
la méthode et votre majorité quand bien
même réduite la majorité socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale fera seul le texte
et vous en profiterez pour décrire le
Sénat comme une assemblée d'inénarrabl
conservateurs soit nous tentons de
limiter les dégâts et c'est ce que nous
allons faire en votant un texte amendé
mais alors vous voulez faire de nous vos
complices de cette réforme à l'envers et
bien nous allons essayer dans cet
exercice difficile à travers les débats
de surmonter l'obstacle car c'est
tactiquement sans doute bien joué pour
vous mais c'est dommage pour notre pays
car cette réforme et vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs vous-même à la fin de votre
propos ne mérite pas un combat
caricatural et vous savez que nous
souhaitons ardemment avancer sur ce
dossier nous en avons terriblement
besoin
et puisqu'on parle de besoins puisque
nous voulons faire des économies j'ai
quelques suggestions à vous faire pour
économiser par exemple 200 millions
d'euros dès l'année
prochaine rétablissez donc la journée de
carence dans la Fonction
publique une autre suggestion à
plusieurs milliards revenez au 39h dans
la sphère non marchande
une autre suggestion encore
assouplissez le statut de la fonction
publique
territoriale avons-nous besoin d'un
régime ultra verrouillé identique à
celui qui protège un agent des impôts ou
un magistrat pour un ingénieur
territorial ou pour un gardien un
gardien de musée
municipal s'il vous plaît si vous ne le
pensez pas donnez de l'air aux
collectivités locales laissez-les
respirer j'en reviens à notre vision de
l'architecture territoriale chacun
connaît ici notre attachement à la
décentralisation et je réaffirme que
nous sommes favorables à une poursuite
de la réforme de nos
collectivité en dépit de ces
imperfections la loi de décembre 2010 a
permis de nombreuses avancées tout le
monde le reconnaît maintenant mais cette
loi n'a jamais eu vocation à clore le
débat nous sommes pour la réforme oui il
faut s'attaquer au millefeuilles
territorial c'est ainsi que nous prenons
une carte des régions au nombre réduit
entre 8 et 10 disposant de compétences
stratégiqu et s'appuyant sur un
département profondément
rénové ce modèle le Sénat le connaît
bien puisque c'est celui qu'avait
défendu nos collègues Yve cratinger et
Jean-Pierre rafarin ici et à plusieurs
reprises d'ailleurs vous avez présenter
votre réforme en vous appuyant sur leur
rapport mais en oubliant un aspect
fondamental c'est que de grandes régions
ne seront efficaces que si elles
s'appuie sur un échelon
départemental à l'exception nous en
convenons des aires urbaines très
denses nous pensons également que dans
un État unitaire
décentralisé un pouvoir d'adaptation
doit s'exercer au niveau local nous nous
militons aussi en faveur de l'adoption
de loi cadre autorisant l'exercice d'un
pouvoir réglementaire
décentralisé nous pensons qu'il s'agit
d'un excellent moyen de maîtriser la
dépense
publique par exemple
essayons de décliner un principe nouveau
concernant le RSA pourquoi le RSA versé
en lozer ou en Mayenne serait-il du même
montant que celui versé à Paris puisque
vous nous avez dit que l'universalité
n'était pas l'uniformité et bien
essayons de réfléchir un peu plus loin
laissez donc au conseils départementaux
volontaire la capacité à tenir compte de
l'adaptation nécessaire enfin on ne peut
pas faire de l'économie d'une réflexion
sur le nombre de communes et vous l'avez
dit oui la commune doit rester l'échelon
de base dans notre organisation
territoriale mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il soit satisfaisant de conserver des
communes de 20 30 40 an et parfois moins
au niveau communal comme pour les
échelons supérieurs le principe de base
doit être le même inciter les élus à
proposer la modernisation et la
rationalisation de leur collectivité en
un mot faire confiance aux
élus nous devons être ici en tant que
législateur nous devons être des
facilitateurs de ces évolutions imaginer
au niveau local une réforme territoriale
qui marche ce n'est pas et ce ne sera
jamais une réforme imposée depuis Paris
le mauvais exemples que je veux citer
sans être trop long sur cet exemple
c'est la loi sur la métropole exmseille
Provence votée par le Parlement avant
que l'étude d'impact ait été réalisée et
sans concertation avec les élus locaux
les communes du bouche de rô ont conçu
un projet équivalent à celui de
l'île-de-fance et elle demande ces
communes à être entendu comme le sont
cell du Grand
Paris nous
devons apporter des solutions innovantes
en matière de fusion de commune 13
fusion de communes ont été réalisé
depuis la loi 2010 c'est-à-dire 13
communes nouvelles sont nées ce bilan
est trop modeste nous devons continuer
et la proposition de loi déposée par
Jacques péissard doit permettre aux élus
de saisir plus facilement cette
opportunité et je vous dirais qu'à
l'échelon départemental c'est la même
chose dans notre conception si les
conseils départementaux veulent
fusionner nous devons faciliter ces
rapprochements par un cadre législatif
souple vous nous proposez dans un autre
domaine de remettre à plat la carte de
l'intercommunalité l'article 14 du
projet de loi dit nôre prévoit je cite
dans l'exposé des motifs une nouvelle
orientation de la rationalisation de la
carte intercommunale resserré autour des
bassins de vie cette notion bassin de
vie comme élément structurant de
l'intercommunalité nous y sommes
favorables le problème c'est que votre
article 14 ne s'arrête pas là il prévoit
surtout un accroissement de la taille
minimale de 5000 à 20000 habitants nous
avons bien entendu tout à l'heure votre
appréciation nuancé et nous serons très
vigilants car nous sommes fermement
opposés à ce seuil appliqué partout de
habitants là aussi j'ai envie de vous
dire universalité ne ne signifie pas
uniformité
oui à des intercommunalités fortes et
spacialement cohérente non à des
rassemblements artificiels autour du
concept de 20000
habitants voilà quelques mots je
voudrais terminer en parlant du
calendrier
électoral quelle confusion Monsieur le
Premier Ministre autant d'attermoimement
sur un sujet aussi important ce n'est
pas sérieux d'ailleurs je pense qu'au
fond de vous-même puisque vous avez été
élu local vous savez que on ne peut pas
gérer des collectivités avec un
calendrier qui évolue chaque jour
pensez-vous que on puisse redonner
confiance aux citoyens et aux électeurs
en procédant ainsi alors si j'ai bien
suivi les élections départemental auront
finalement lieu en mars 2015 soit nous
en prenons acte mais je me permets une
remarque c'est que si nous voulons des
conseils départementaux qui fonctionnent
normalement
il faut que le mandat puisse aller à
l'échéance des 6 ans c'est-à-dire que le
mandat doit aller jusqu'à l'année 2021
il n'est pas concevable qu'il y ait une
exception pour ce
mandat en venant vous exprimer devant le
Sénat vous rendez hommage Monsieur le
Premier Ministre au travail de notre
assemblée mais aussi à tout le travail
qui va s'accomplir dans les mois qui
viennent le Sénat représente ésentant
constitutionnel de nos collectivités
territoriales il entend pleinement jouer
ce rôle nous voulons avec la nouvelle
majorité redonner toute sa force à la
voix du Sénat le Sénat doit apporter à
nouveau chers
collègues sa plusvalue son expertise qui
s'appuie notamment par des élus
enracinés dans leur territoire et aussi
par le vote de textes qui sont
confrontter avec la vision de
l'Assemblée
nationale évidemment monsieur le Premier
ministre ce Sénat là des élus enracinés
dans leur territoire nous avons bien
compris que vous n'en vouliez plus
depuis la loi sur le non cumule de
mandat applicable également au Sénat
nous le regrettons et nous continuerons
tant que c'est encore possible apporter
notre vision des territoires celle du
Sénat celle des élus des territoires je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président la
parole est au président Bruno rotaillot
pour le groupe UMP vous avez la parole
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Ministre mesdames Messieurs
les les ministres chers collègues vous
me permettrez de commencer mon
intervention en saluant l'initiative de
notre président du Sénat Gérard archer
qui a invité le Premier ministre à
remettre en perspective cette réff merci
à notre président merci aussi au Premier
ministre de la avoir accepté j'espère
qu'à l'heure qu'il est il ne le regrette
pas
d'ailleurs je voudrais dire que cette
remise en perspective était nécessaire
elle était doublement nécessaire
nécessaire d'abord parce que tous qui
que nous soyons quels que soient les
sièges où nous sommes nous sommes
désireux de remettre le Sénat au cœur de
cette réforme mais nécessaire ser plus
encore pour sortir de la confusion car
enfin cette réforme est née dans la
panique de la prê municipale et elle est
marquée par le double saut le double
signe de l'improvisation et de la
contradiction improvisation avec une
carte régionale dessinée sur un coin de
table improvisation toujours avec des
économies proclamées sans jamais en
fournir la moindre justification et pour
cause et contradiction puisqu'on est
parti avec le discours du président de
la République en corise qui proclamait
son amour pour les département et je ne
parle pas de l'engagement numéro 54
pendant la présidentielle en passant par
la suppression des départements pour
arriver désormais un département à trois
vitesses où est la logique sans compter
d'ailleurs que pendant tout ce temps-l
où on discutait suppression des
départements il y avait le grand
remembrement le grand découpage de tous
les cantons de France où est cette
logique là
encore il fallait donc sortir de
cintprovisation de ces
contradictions et je pense que cette
confusion a été sanctionnée dans les
urnes le 28 septembre dernier alors
est-ce à dire qu'aujourd'hui on ne doit
rien faire est-ce à dire qu'aujourd'hui
la nouvelle majorité
sénatorial doit se présenter devant vous
complètement bloqué dans une posture
pavlovienne de l'opposition ça n'est pas
notre état
d'esprit nous voulons que le Sénat
puisse imprimer sa marque mais pas à
n'importe quelle condition il y a deux
conditions la première c'est que nous ne
nous contenterons pas de
parole les amendements que j'ai vu
notamment sur la carte ont produit sur
moi le même effet qu'ils ont eu sur le
président mard
je vous ai entendu
parler de volonté de dialogue vous ne
souhaitez pas la confrontation mais si
c'est simplement pour entendre le Sénat
débattre si c'est simplement pour ne
retenir aucun de nos amendements vous
aurez un sénat de combat Monsieur le
Premier Ministre
croyez-moi ce que nous voulons ce que
nous voulons la feuille de route que
nous voulons c'est le
rapport rfarin rafarin cratager pas la
découpe dans toute sa logique dans
toutes ses conséquences la deuxième
conditioniction aussi la deuxème des
conditions de l'ouverture des sénateurs
c'est que vous acceptiez de donner non
seulement du sens mais de redonner une
vision vous avez commencé à le faire
mais imparfaitement je vous dirai
pourquoi tout à l'heure à cette réforme
et je pense qu'il va falloir trancher
pas seulement dans le discours mais dans
les actes et dans le texte trois
contradictions fondamentales la première
des
contradictions recentralisation
ou
décentralisation un détour rapide par
l'histoire de France puisque vous vous
en avez parlé la France c'est
l'obsession de l'unité l'unité
capétienne l'unité impériale l'unité de
la République oui la République une et
indivisible mais au fil du temps mais au
fil
on s'est aperçu que l'unité nationale ne
pouvait pas aller sans une forme de
respiration territorial ce sont les
provinces sous l'Ancien Régime les
communes les départements sous la
République c'est cet effort permanent de
synthèse entre l'unité et la diversité
et cette perspective historique monsieur
le Premier ministre mes chers collègues
cette perspective
historique
multiséculaire a donné une vision
politique pas seulement depuis 30 ans
dès le 19e siècle les grandes lois de
liberté communale les grandes lois de
liberté
départementale et puis bien sûr le
général de Gaulle sa tentative de
régionalisation les régions puissance de
demain puissance économique de demain et
puis vous avez cité bien sûr François
mitan mais ce que vous nous proposez
jusqu'à présent avant vre discours mais
je veux savoir si c'est un virage un 1è
virage ou une vraie inflexion ce que
vous nous proposez c'est tout l'inverse
c'est une rupture c'est un recul le
texte que nous avons pour le moment est
un texte de recentralisation
recentralisation dans la méthode puisque
la carte a été dessinée non pas avec les
provinciaux l'île-de-fance ne bougeit
pas elle a été dessinée avec les féodaux
vous le savez bien une carte qui était
dessinée avant même de réfléch
compéces et c'était une grave
erreur c'était une grave erreur parce
que vous avez pris le risque d'ouvrir la
boîte de Pandore vous avez pris le
risque de
déconnecter les communautés
d'appartenance tourné vers les héritages
historiques plutôt que les communautés
de projets les communautés de destin
tendu vers l'avenir tendu vers les
projets vous avez au final renforcé le
communautarisme territorial
Monsieur le Premier Ministre
recentralisation dans la forme
recentralisation aussi dans le fond vous
avez même
juxteaposé auprès du jacobinisme
parisien vous avez Ju àabosé un nouveau
jacobinisme régional car enfin des
grandes régions qui absorbent toutes les
compétences y compris de proximité des
départements des schémas prescriptif qui
s'impose sur toutes les autres
collectivités en cascade c'est aussi une
une forme de recentralisation et quand
j'entends voyez quand j'entends chers
collègues le président de
l'ARF
déclarer dans un journal quotidien
régional qu'il a honte à chaque fois
qu'il intervient avant le préfet de
région je me dis où on est la France
n'est pas un pays de tradition fédérale
et je m'oppose et mon groupe s'opposera
toujours à ce que derrière ce
régionalistme plus ou moins assumé on
veulent démembrer le pays non la
République française est une et
indivisible nous sommes une communauté
nationale et les grandes régions nous le
voulons bien mais à la condition que les
compétences soient justement partagées
parce que sinon nous feront des
mamouthes recentralisation aussi vous
avez dit tout à l'heure dans votre
discours que au moment où vous parliez
vous avaviez même pas d'ailleurs parlé
encore des départements vous avez parlé
nous voulons renforcer le rôle euh des
de l'État dans les départements votre
Ministre d'intérieur avait indiqué aussi
dans un quotidien du soir qu'il voulait
il souhaitait renforcer le rôle des
préfets dans les départements
recentralisation recentralisation aussi
pour la première fois vous avez ouvert
une porte nous la saisirons sur le
deuxème texte en parler de l'emploi en
parlant de l'économie mais jusqu'à
présent vous ne remettez en cause aucun
des grands doublan qu'il y a au niveau
de la région et au niveau du département
je pouvais je pourrais vous cit une
liste sur les aides à la pierre le
logement l'économie l'emploi l'eau et
cetera où franchement l'État est le
double honneur en
chef nous sommes stupéfaits
qu'aujourd'hui le doubleur en chef
reproche finalement aux collectivités de
double nez il faut d'abord mettre mes
chers collègues un peu d'or dans les
compétences de
l'État ministre c'est cette incapacité à
penser dans le même mouvement jusqu'à
présent la réforme territoriale et la
réforme de l'État qui vous rend
incapable de produire le moindre rau
d'économie globalement et qui vous
obstruit le chemin pour une véritable
réforme de
l'État nous vous proposerons dès la dès
le 2è texte non seulement une
répartition adapté aux compétences entre
les régions les départements les
communes et les intercommunalités mais
nous souhaitons en même temps avoir une
vision claire des compétences de l'État
qui pourrait être transféré pour que on
est aussi un texte de décentralisation
qui soit conforme au grand mouvement de
décentralisation que notre pays connaît
et vous l'avez rappelé depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années l'amenait avac cette
phrase superbe d'ailleurs il indiquait
que la centralisation c'est toujours
l'apoplexie au centre et la la paralysie
pardon à la périphérie je crois que on
est au cœur de ce débat donc la
décentralisation plutôt que la
recentralisation mais aussi la
préférence pour la proximité plutôt que
la préférence pour
l'éloignement parce que la réforme telle
que vous la portez depuis des mois et
des mois c'est quoi ce sont des grandes
régions avec l'effacement des
départements et ce sont des grandes
intercommunalités avec l'affaiblissement
après-demain ou demain même des communes
cela ne peut pas marcher ça ne peut pas
marcher parce que ça correspondrait à
une forme de bureaucratisation de la
France avoir des grandes administrations
régionales qui concentrerait toutes les
administrations départementales
puisqu'il y aurait plus de département
alors vous feriez des administrations
régionales de milliers de milliers de
fonctionnaires d'agents territoriaux
c'est pas ce que nous souhaitons et en
plus
cette déterritorialisation ne correspond
pas au remèdes qu'il faut apporter aux
trois grandes frises françaises quels
sont ces trois grandes crises françaises
la première la
démocratie la démocratie nationale
fonctionne mal les Français n'ont plus
confiance mes chers collègues en leurs
élus nationaux ils gardent un lien de
conscience de confiance avec les élus
locaux cette réforme doit aussi avoir un
visage humain
et vous avez oublié la dimension humaine
dans cette réforme pourquoi parce que il
y a une loi humaine qui veut que une
institution proche soit une institution
aimée une institution lointaine soit une
institution dont on se méfie tout
simplement la démocratie nationale se
reconstruira par la démocratie locale ça
n'est pas en affaiblissant ses
liens entre les
citoyens et leurs élus que vous
parviendrez à revigorer la démocratie
nationale c'est la grande leçon des
Grecs certes leur démocratie elle était
naissante elle n'était pas parfaite mais
elle est née dans la cité dans un espace
humain première des crises françaises
l'autre des crises françaises aussi la
fracture territoriale je suis heureux
que vous en ayez parlé je suis un
électeur de Christophe guiloui le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez
des métropoles bien sûr elles sont
importantes bien sûr on a souhaité les
conforter qui sont en prise avec la
mondialisation et puis vous avez une
France périphérique la France des
oubliés la France des des Invisibles la
France des fragilité sociale qui a
l'impression d'être abandonné et bien si
vous n'avez plus de département qui
assure la cohésion territoriale cette
France là vous renforcerit son sentiment
d'abandon et ne nous dites pas que on il
faut encore attendre 5 ans pour
déterminer l'avenir du département si
vous nous dites dans 5 ans on verra ce
sera trop tard vous ne pouvez pas a
suscité tant d'instabilité déjà la
baisse des dotations c'est une
instabilité
fondamentale et ça n'est pas mes chers
collègues seulement 11 milliards ce sera
en cumule entre 2013 fin 2013 et la fin
2017 moins 28 milliards d'euros par
rapport au niveau des dotations de la
fin de 2013 ce sera une ponction
terrible sur l'investissement la
fracture territoriale bien sûr les
départements là aussi sont un remède et
enfin la trè des crises sur laquelle je
veux insister c'est l'économie j'en ai
parlé avec la baisse probable des
investissements mais c'est une fausse
conception de la modernité et de la
mondialisation de
penser et surtout d'assimiler la
puissance à la taille la masse à
l'agilité si vous donnez aux régions
toutes les compétences si vous donnez
aux régions un des orateurs précédents
en a parlé la compétence de transport
scolaire mais mais c'est absolument
incohérent si vous voulez agrandir les
périmètres releverz l'horizon donnez aux
nouvelles grandes région des compétences
programmatiques et seulement quelques
compétences
stratégiques j'entends depuis des années
et des années les présidents de conseil
généraux qui nous dit mais l'État ne
payent pas ses dettes le RSA la PA la PC
depuis 2004 c'est une catastrophe
j'entends les présidents de conseil
régionaux qui nous disent nons plus
d'autonomie fiscale et financière du
tout nous ne vivons que de dotation
c'est la réalité et j'entends les maires
de nos communes et j'ai fait la campagne
sénatoriale ces maires qui nous disent
nous n'avons plus les moyens d'investir
parce que l'État nous sert trop le le
kik voilà la réalité et bien par rapport
à cela c'est pas depuis 6 mois un an ou
2 ans c'est depuis des années alors
essayons d'avancer ensemble pour faire
en sorte que les régions retrouvent de
l'oxygène que les départements arrivent
à avoir une vraie responsabilité et que
les communes puissent enfin à nouveau
investir alors pour réussir la réforme
oui j'ose le dire ici à cette tribune il
ne faut pas mettre en cause les élus les
élus sont les hussards de la République
les élus sont là tous les jours dans les
petites communes comme dans les
départements et dans les régions pour
rendre les services pour répondre et
chaque fois que l'on mettra les élus en
cause on attaquera la République que ce
soit la gauche ou la droite les nous
devons toujours les soutenir nous devons
toujours les défendre parce que ce son
eux qui font vivre le service public
dans nos territoire mais il ne faut pas
céder non plus au conservatisme parce
qu'il faudra avancer nous ne sommes pas
des conservateurs il y en a pas dans
cette assemblée il n'y a que des
sénateurs et des sénatrices qui veulent
avancer et qui veulent bouger et enfin
mes chers collègues là aussi nous nous
retrouvons toutes et tous n'pposons pas
jamais l'urbain et le rural npposons pas
les villes et les campagnes disons que
la ruralité est une chance pour notre
pays la ruralité c'est un joyau dans la
ruralité a de l'activité économique de
la culture de l'artisanat du tourisme
oui prenons en compte cette réalité la
ruralité est une chance pour notre pays
comme les villes comme les densités
urbaines en sont une pour notre pays
faisonsles avancer ensemble il faut donc
faire confiance il faut donc faire
confiance au territoires c'est par les
territoires que la réforme se fera à
trois conditions de clarifier les
compétences mais le Premier ministre
nous l'a proposé de clarifier les
structures parce qu'on voit bien
qu'elles doivent avancer et de clarifier
les finances parce qu'on voit bien qu'on
avons du mal à y arriver et nous partons
notre groupe sur des principes
fondamentaux ces principes fondamentaux
sont assez clairs le premier c'est la
solidarité oui la solidarité entre les
citoyens et la solidarité entre les
territoires celle-là elle est
indispensable il est ensuite la
proximité et vous avez eu raison les uns
et les autres de dire que nous aurions
pu perdre la proximité si d'autres
projets avaient vu le jour j'ai entendu
ce que vient de nous dire le Premier
ministre la proximité sera préservée
elle est indispensable pour que nos
concitoyens retrouve les chemins de la
République là il ne croi plus en la
politique là il ne croi plus à la
société il ne croit plus à la nation
parce qu'ils sont isolés parce qu'il n'y
a plus de service public parce que les
services publics ont déserté nos
territoires et parce qu'enfin ils sont
isolés de l'emploi voilà la réalité la
proximité est indispensable elle est
indispensable aussi pour mettre en avant
le professionnalisme des fonctionnaires
territoriaux qui jouent un rôle
essentiel de lien entre les élus et les
territoires et puis évidemment sur la
clarté mais le Premier ministre nous a
rassuré tout à l'heure ce ce qu'il nous
propose c'est beaucoup de clarté et
enfin de l'efficacité alors mes chers
collègues Mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs je pense que nous pouvons nous
retrouver peut-être nous retrouver sur
un socle territorial commun si nous
regardons le texte et pas le contexte
bien sûr que nous avons des débats
politiques bien sûr que nous pourrons
nous opposer sur plein de sujets mais ce
socle territorial commun que notre
groupe vous propose il est assez clair
tout d'abord constitué de grandes
régions de grandes régions stratèges de
grandes régions qui innovent de grandes
régions qui orientent avec des schémas
avec évidemment les fonds européens
c'est déjà le cas mais enfin l'économie
l'économie ça doit être la compétence
essentiel des régions ces grandes
régions tout à l'heure Bruno rotill a
dit qu'il voulait bien avancer
françoisqueto aussi nous verrons les
compétences je vais venir mais sur les
grandes régions le rapport
rafarin cting le disait déjà nous avons
besoin de grandes régions et nous
pouvons nous entendre c'est pas un
problème de féodau sur un coin de table
c'est tout simplement avoir dessiné une
nouvelle carte des régions dont on parle
depuis 20 ans que personne n'a eu ni le
courage de faire ni oser le faire et que
ce gouvernement et que le Parlement va
enfin réaliser voilà une réforme en
profondeur et une réforme
structurel il faut évidemment renforcer
les intercommunalités et là nous sommes
toutes est tous d'accord et le Premier
ministre l'a évoqué il faut donner des
objectifs le premier objectif qui a été
donné sur les intercommunalités c'était
dans la loi Sarkozy Filion et on se
rappelle ce qui s'est passé dans les
CDCI et les préfets en force voulant
faire rentrer les communes dans les
interc on a vu ce qui s'était passé et
le gouvernement dans son premier texte a
donné le chiffr de 20000 et je suis très
heureux que le premier ministre ait
entendu l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale parce que ce chiffre de 200
ce chiffre de 20000 n'est pas pour nous
acceptable et nous travaillerons avec
d'autres mais il s'agit pas ni d'en rire
ni de faire des remarques nous pensons
nous pensons que dans certains endroits
il faudra des grandes interc à beaucoup
plus de 20000 et beaucoup plus de 100000
mais en zone rurale en zone de montagne
en zone périphérique il faudra des plus
petites intercommunalités qui soient des
bassins de vie là-dessus mes chers
collègues nous pouvons nous retrouver et
puis évidemment il faut affirmer le rôle
indispensable des communes le rôle
indispensable des communes et toutes ces
communes c'est notre richesse et en même
temps ça a été évoqué récemment par
l'association des mares de France il
faut aussi si elle le souhaite inciter
les communes à se regrouper à mutualiser
parce qu'il y a tellement de petites
communes que les choses peuvent avancer
pas de façon imposée mais de façon
volontaire et bien là déjà nous nous
retrouvons enfin entre les deux entre
ces grandes régions et entre les
communes et les interc oui le Premier
ministre l'a évoqué il faut des conseils
départementaux qui joue ce rôle de
proximité ce rôle à la fois de
solidarité territoriale et de solidarité
humaine et je remercie le Premier
ministre d'avoir fait cette avancée
parce que pour nous elle est
indispensable le maintien des conseils
départementaux dans nos zones
territoriales rurales est indispensable
peut-être même peut-être même d'ailleurs
dans les départements plus grands à
condition de clarifier les compétences
et à condition que les conseils
départementaux ne fassent pas tout comme
ils le font aujourd'hui parce que si
c'était le cas alors nous serions au
bout d'un système qui qui ne pourrait
pas fonctionner clarifions les choses
solidarité urbaine solidarité humaine
solidarité territoriale oui les conseils
départementaux dans cette dans dans
cette dans ces pas du tout dans ces
territoires est indispensable parce que
nous ne voulons garder non parce que
nous voulons garder à la fois des
conseillers régionaux et des conseillers
départementaux nous nous ne sommes pas
nous ne sommes pas ceux qui disont il
faut réduire le nombre d'élus non il
faut des élus qui soient respectés enfin
avant dernier point il faut redéfinir le
rôle de l'État déconcentré oui oui
monsieur le Premier ministre vous l'avez
évoqué il faut que l'État fasse des
effort encore aller plus loin dans la
déconcentration aller plus loin dans la
décentralisation aller plus loin le
transfert et vous l'avez dit Monsieur le
Premier Ministre et nous en sommes
satisfaits parce que ce n'est pas
uniquement les collectivités locales et
les élus territoriaux qui doivent faire
des efforts il faut aussi que l'État en
faceasse et enfin dernier point de ce
socle territorial commun que nous vous
proposons c'est celui de sécuriser les
fonctionnaires départementaux qui ont
été ballotés au gré des diverses réforme
du conseiller territorial d'alors à la
suppression des conseils départementaux
d'aujourd'hui à la nouvelle formule qui
sera présentée oui comme élu
départemental je sais que les
fonctionnaires territoriaux s'inquiètent
et c'est la raison pour laquelle dans le
socle commun territorial que nous vous
proposons nous pouvons être d'accord
pour sécuriser les fonctionnaires
territoriaux sur le devenir
professionnel voilà mes chers collègues
mesdames Messieurs si nous avançons
tranquillement tranquillement en faisant
fi de toutes les polémiques en faisant
fi de toute la politique politicienne
peut-être en nous en nous accordant en
nous accordant pardon que tout n'a pas
été aussi bien fait que que nous aurions
pu l'espérer peut-être aurions pu éviter
quelques attermoements quelques
changements de cap mais enfin ce n'est
pas le premier gouvernement qui agit de
la sorte n n'ayant pas la mémoire courte
n'ayant pas la mémoire courte
alors Monsieur
le monsieur le Président du Sénat vous
avez souhaité lors de votre élection que
le Sénat soit respecté que le Sénat soit
entendu que le Sénat soit écouté dans sa
conclusion le Premier ministre a dit si
chacun joue son rôle gouvernement
Parlement il y aura une chance pour que
la réforme puisse se mettre en place
c'est ce que les socialiste le groupe
socialiste et apparenté du Sénat vous
propose c'est de nous retrouver sur
l'essentiel celui qui va parler à nos
concitoyens sur la proximité aux élus
pour les rassurer aux fonctionnaires
territoriaux pour les encour AG tout
simplement en disant des grandes régions
des conseils départementaux de proximité
des communes des interc rénovés une
clarification des compétences la
redéfinition du rôle de l'État et enfin
privilégier et aider les fonctionnaires
territoriaux à reprendre le moral si
nous faisons cela Mesdames et Messieurs
mes chers collègues je pense que nous
pouvons le faire ensemble nous pouvons
ne pas être d'accord sur toutes les
lignes du texte de loi sur tel ou tel
découpage de telle ou telle région je
sais que nous avons des différences mais
sur le fond ce qui compte c'est que pour
que le Sénat soit respecté il faut que
le Sénat avance dans le sens de la
modernité dans le sens de la réforme et
la réforme qui est proposée par le
Premier ministre par le gouvernement
d'abord sur les régions ensuite sur la
nouvelle organisation du de notre
territoire républicain est quelque chose
de très important nous sommes tous des
républicains convaincus la France est
une indivisible mais elle est diverse
alors oui défendons la République
française mais défend la République
française décentralisée pour la force de
nos convictions la force de
décentralisation la force des élus pour
être en Phe avec la population en
solidarité avec les citoyens et surtout
pour faire en sorte que demain nos
collectivités locales et les moyens de
se développer de travailler en réseau
dans l'intérêt de notre pays je vous
remercie merci
président
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est maintenant à notre collègue Renand
DC pour le groupe
écologiste avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre madamees et messieurs
les ministres mes chers
collègues les écologistes défendent
depuis toujours un renforcement des
compétences des collectivités
territorial car nous considérons que
c'est bien au plus près des citoyens et
en s'adaptant aux spécificités de chaque
territoire que nous sommes en capacité
de développer au mieux l'action publique
le projet des écologistes en la matière
est connu et nous sommes constants dans
nos propositions autour du renforcement
du couple région
intercommunalité avec évidemment un
suffrage universel direct pour les
conseillers communautaires en charge des
grandes politiques de la vie
quotidienne tout nouveau projet de loi
renforçant les compétences des élus
locaux et régionaux permettant une plus
grande lisibilité de l'action publique
territoriale nous semble donc aller dans
le bon sens et nous sommes prêts à le
sout
nous avons donc applaudi monsieur le
Premier ministre à une bonne part de vos
annonces en avril dernier sur ce
nécessaire engagement d'un processus
fort et rapide pour redessiner les
contours de l'action publique
territoriale la rendre plus cohérente
avec comme symbole de cette volonté de
faire simple et efficace l'annonce de la
suppression du département vieille
revendication des écologistes le projet
pouvait paraître audacieux vous sombliez
prêt à bousculer tous les conservatismes
et nous nous apprétions déj à investir
nos modestes forces sénatoriales à vos
côtés pour vous aider dans la bataille
difficile qui s'annonçait dans cet
hémicycle face à tous les conservatismes
que bousculit déjà votre volontarisme
affiché aujourd'hui monsieur le Premier
ministre nous répondons présent mais
nous sommes quand même un peu
désorientés avouons-le où est en effet
le champ de bataille où est la ligne de
front les lignes ont tellement bougé
depuis 6 mois les alliances sont scellé
dénoué recomposé et plus personne ne s'y
retrouve vraiment et je n'ose même pas
évoquer le besoin d'une boussole
indiquant le Nord car mes propos
pourraent être lu comme une prise de
position sur l'avenir le redécoupage des
régions septentrionales de notre pays il
y a un problème de méthode et
reconnaissons donc l'intérêt de ce débat
aujourd'hui pour essayer d'y voir plus
clair j'insiste tout d'abord ça a été
fait avant moi sur l'ordre de
présentation des projets de loi si on
peut quand même comprendre ne soyons pas
caricaturaux quelques urgences par
rapport aux contraintes
constitutionnelles du calendrier
électoral il n'en paraît pas moins
évident qu'annoncer un aussi vaste
redécoupage des régions françaises avant
d'avoir présidé précisé les compétence
n'a guerre contribué à la clarté du
débat si je prends l'exemple que je
connais le mieux celui du redécoupage de
l'Ouest peut-être que le statut C qu'on
soutenu plus par calculs électoraux de
court terme et patriotisme
d'organisation que par vision d'avenir
nombre de grands élus des deux régions
n'auraient pas résisté à la prise de
conscience collective des nouvelle
logique de planification qui sont
inscrit dans la future loi que
présentera mari-elise Lebranchu on peut
s'interroger est-ce que les élus
régionaux de ces deux régions
administratives Bretagne et pile la
Loire aurait pu continuer à soutenir un
statut qu indéfendable sur le fond s'il
avait fallu expliquer aux citoyens que
nous aurions ainsi demain un schéma
prescripteur régional d'aménagement du
territoire qui ne chapauterait même pas
l'axe majeur d'aménagement de l'Ouest
qui est l'axe renante qui va se
retrouver tronçonné entre deux schémas
descriptif différents l'incohérence
devait alors sauter aux yeux et
l'immobilisme qui a trouvé dans l'Ouest
tant de défenseurs dans les deux régions
sen serait peut-être trouvé ébranlé j'en
viens donc aussi à la question qui vient
nous occuper pendant deux ou trois jours
celle de la bonne carte pour la France
du 21e siècle je crois Monsieur le
Premier Ministre avoir compris votre
logique une France reconstruite autour
de grandes aires urbaines censé
entraîner l'ensemble de leur territoire
une grande région pour Bordeaux Toulouse
Lyon Marseille ou lire une armature
urbaine pour la Normandie ou l'est de la
France ça peut se comprendre se défendre
même si la démonstration aurait gagné en
clarté si vous nous aviez expliqué
précisément comment la richesse se
redistribuera entre Toulouse et foie ou
entre Lyon et orillac l'absence de
définition des mécanismes de solidarité
territorial interne autour de ces
grandes régions nuit probablement à la
démonstration et réduit l'adhésion à
cette réforme de la part de territoire
se sentant aujourd'hui faible et
excentré mais nous avons encore le temps
d'y retravailler dans le discussion de
la loi le branchu sur ces mécanismes de
solidarité c'est un des socles d'une
réforme réussi cette réforme n'a
également de sens que dans la
construction d'un vouloir vivre ensemble
clairement exprimé plus de 2 sièclle
après la création des départements 60
ans après les circonscriptions d'action
régionale quelle grande opportunité que
la création d'une nouvelle carte à
l'image de la France aujourd'hui
malheureusement ici monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez refusé d'aller au
bout de la logique que vous aviez
pourtant initié en limitant la réforme à
l'alternative fusion de région ou
statutco vous avez raté l'occasion d'une
carte partagée comprise et largement
défendue ce débat passionne pourtant les
territoires a mis des dizaines de
milliers de personnes dans les rues à
Nantes ou à Strasbourg fais la une des
journaux régionaux pourquoi ne pas avoir
organisé de grands débat public avec
votes des assemblées concernées autour
de différents scénarios voire des
consultations populaires là où il n'y
avait pas consensus c'était un débat
désiré dans nos territoires il y a
aujourd'hui beaucoup de frustration dans
nombre de territoire de l'avoir occulté
monsieur le Premier ministre mais
pourquoi donc ce refus de renforcer la
parole citoyenne d'intégrer la vie des
habitants permettre des initiatives
citoyennes ce n'est pas la chianlie ou
la boîte de Pandore comme je l'ai
entendu c'est au contraire conforter le
citoyen dans sa capacité d'intervention
dans le débat public c'est conforter la
démocratie locale et nationale nous
savons tous aujourd'hui combien il faut
d'urgence relégitimer le citoyen au cœur
du débat politique pour ne pas le
laisser aux désespéran entre abstention
et vote extrême et l'absence l'exemple
de l'Alsace est ici central sur l'Alsace
les choses sont extrêmement claires les
élus régionaux les élus départementaux
les habitants de manière majoritaire se
sont tous prononcés pour une
collectivité unique c'est aujourd'hui
sur la table le Sénat le soutient
monsieur le Premier ministre si jamais
vous revenez sur qui a été clairement
exprimé vous allez contre ce que vous
nous avez dit tout à l'heure de d'avoir
une organisation territoriale qui
correspond à une France diverse et je
crois que pour nous groupe écologiste
nous serons extrêmement attentifs sur la
viille nous porterons sur la fin du
processus sur la réponse qui sera faite
aux Alsaciens et nous soutenons
évidemment ce projet de collectivité
territoriale unique
d'alsas plus généralement à l'échelle
des départements pourquoi di le droit
d'option souplesse nécessaire à la
cohérence d'ensemble le Sénat en
première lecture avait facilité ce droit
d'option l'Assemblée nationale avec le
soutien du gouvernement l'a supprimé
nous le regrettons profondément ce
besoin de souplesse au service d'une
carte partagé dépasser pourtant les
clivages politiques habituels nous
n'étions pas très loin d'un consensus et
je vous dis ici au nom du groupe
écologiste notre incompréhension de la
position gouvernementale sur le fond
comme sur la capacité de respecter les
travaux du Sénat quand le Sénat exprime
lui-même sa volonté de trouver des
consensus plus globalement sur le rôle
du département vous savez que les
écologistes ont toujours plaidé pour un
renforcement de la région allant donc de
pair avec la réduction des compétences
départementales je l'ai dit en
introduction c'est la le sens de la loi
en tout cas c'était dans le préambule de
la loi que mariis Lebranchu devait nous
présenter nous étions dans cette
perspective claire de la disparition du
département depuis lors l'histoire c'est
un peu complexifié et la disparition de
l'échelon départemental n'est plus à
l'ordre du jour cette évolution dans le
discours a été un peu caricaturé parfois
réduite à un accord avec un groupe de la
majorité voire un accord un peu
politicien je veux dire ici que nous
rejoignons aujourd'hui en partie ses
conclusions sur l'avenir du département
autant les départements n'avait pas de
sens dans de petites régions autant leur
maintien comme échelon entre petites
intercommunalités et grande région avec
les compétences principalement de
l'action sociale fait sens pour avoir
comme d'autres échanger avec nombre
d'élus d'intercommunalité de mon
département je peux aussi témoigner de
leur refus de se voir confier les
compétences sociales et donc leur
volonté de maintien d' échelons
départemental sur ce point je crois que
le débat a fait évoluer les visions y
compris chez les Sénateurs écologistes
mais pour autant ne faut-il pas faire
évoluer ce département je vous propose
même monsieur le Premier ministre un
slogan simple moins de région moins de
département c'est simple et lisible je
prends toujours l'exemple de l'axe
nandren un département unique de Haute
Bretagne entre n terrain avec des
problématiques territoriales qui sont
exactement les mêmes pour l'ensemble des
territoires entre les deux grandes
métropoles c'est le sens de l'histoire
et pour citer le président mard faites
plus confiance à l'intelligence
territoriale dans ce cadre là sur
l'avenir du département reposons-nous
demain alors je sait que ça ne passera
pas ici tout de suite la question du
bicamérisme est-ce que demain ces
grandes régions avec des compétences
fortes doivent être géré uniquement par
un scrutin proportionnel au suffrage
direct ou est-ce que deux chambres avec
une chambre plus issue des territoires
ne permettrait pas un meilleur équilibre
et répondrait à un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes qui se sont exprimées dans
le débat je pense que c'est une piste à
explorer c'est une piste qui existe
ailleurs en Europe elle n'est absolument
pas exogène au débat de même mais nous
n'aurons pas le temps d'y revenir ce
soir la question du statut de l'élu
local est une question clé de cette
réforme les élus locaux ont aujourd'hui
un rôle fondamental dans le maintien de
la cohésion sociale et territoriale dans
ce pays il faudra revenir sur le statut
de l'élu local il faudra de nouveau le
renforcer et il faudra et ça a été dit
juste avant moi rassurer les
fonctionnaires territoriaux qui
s'inquiètent beaucoup pour leur avenir
qui ont effectivement l'impression
d'être aujourd'hui balloté au gré des
débats ils sont eux aussi des acteurs
clés de la cohésion de nos territoires
monsieur le Premier
ministre nous avons donc aujourd'hui
énormément d'interrogations sur cette
réforme c'est une réforme au milieu du
gay dans le brouillard de ces
compétences nouvelles mal définies
permettront-elles le maintien de la
cohésion territoriale ou son
renforcement dans l'inconnu et ça a été
dit de la place de l'État demain dans
cette nouvelle architecture dans
l'angoisse aussi d'élus locaux craignant
de perdre pied par manque de moyens
financiers et bien dans ce brouillard
nous avons effectivement un peu de mal à
apercevoir l'autre rive pour dissiper ce
brouillard il faut aujourd'hui un
souffle décentralisateur bien plus fort
nous sentons bien quelques brises
agréables mais toujours aussi bien
légère Monsieur le Premier Ministre pour
franchir la rivière un bon et préférable
à une étape surtout au milieu du gay le
groupe écologiste soutiendra une réforme
ambitieuse et lisible mais pas une
réforme qui resterait au milieu de la
rivière je vous
remercie merci à notre collègue la
parole est maintenant à madame la
Présidente ellian Assassi pour le groupe
communiste républicain et
citoyens ça
va vous avez la parole madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues merci d'abord au président
Larcher pour votre initiative et merci à
Monsieur le Premier Ministre d'être
parmi nous cet après-midi pour clarifier
cette réforme territoriale avant toute
chose quit à empiété sur mon temps de
parole permettez-moi de vous faire part
de l'émotion de mon groupe après le
décès dans des conditions qui restent
encore à déterminer du jeune Rémi fress
qui qui manifestait pour la suspension
des travaux du barrage Sivens dans le
dans le Tarne on ne peut pas mourir à 21
ans nos pensées sont tournés vers sa
famille ses proches et nous espérons que
la lumière sur ce drame sera faite au
plus vite mes chers collègues notre
débat de cet après-midi ne peut pas à
notre avis être déconnecté de ce qui se
passe dans le pays chômage en constante
progression croissance quasi nulle
demande agonisante et érité bien
présente alors que les déficits sont à
leur paroxisme de manière générale et
principalement dans ces circonstances
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que les élus
les collectivités sont souvent les
derniers remparts certains disent les
boucliers contre la dislocation d' tissu
social monsieur le Premier ministre en
quelque sorte avec votre déclaration
d'aujourd'hui sur la réforme
territoriale vous nous présentez à
nouveau votre projet de société libéral
social libéral je vous laisse le soin de
le qualifier pour ma part ce qui
m'intéresse sont les contenus et c'est
le sens mais une chose est sûre ce
projet tourne le dos aux valeurs qui ont
construit la gauche au fil des décennies
peu sont celles et ceux qui croient
aujourd'hui que l'objectif de votre
politique est de répondre aux espoirs de
mai 2012 d'ailleurs vous ne cessez
vous-même de le répéter vous voulez
casser le lien avec cette gauche que
vous avez renié alors qu'elle fondent
pourtant votre seule L timité politique
votre gouvernement a entériné une
politique de l'offre conforme au souhait
du meddeef et pour la financer vous vous
attaquez à notre protection sociale à
notre code du travail et à nos
collectivités en résumé vous demandez
des effort à la population pour
améliorer la situation du pays alors que
vous faites des cadeaux aux entreprises
et à leurs actionnaires autant de choix
qui n'offre pas de différence de fond
avec la politique économique menée par
la droite entre deux mots vous ne
laissez qu'un seul choix aux Français
celui de choisir entre le moins pire
soit la réduction de 50 milliards que
vous proposez soit le pire avec une
réduction de 120 milliards voulu par la
droite mais pire ou moins pire c'est
toujours pire et ce n'est ni pour l'un
ni pour l'autre que nous avons voté
certes vous n'êtes pas monsieur le
Premier ministre je dois reconnaître le
seul responsable des évolutions
libérales en matière économique et
sociale de la société il en est de même
pour le sujet qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui l'organisation du territoire
cette évolution remonte à de longues
années après les grands espoirs suscités
par les lois de décentralisation de 82
la loi constitutionnelle du 28 mars 2003
fut celle qui a amorcé le morcellement
de la République le Premier ministre de
l'époque notre collègue monsieur rafarin
en avait fait sa réforme clé la clé
d'une politique libérale totalement
revendiquée dont l'objectif aé d'opérer
de vastes transferts d'activités
publiques rentables vers le secteur
privé et de diminuer considérablement
les dépenses publi les réformes engagées
par Nicolas Sarkozi ont poursuivi une
logique du désengagement financier et
politique de l'État avec une méthode
celle de la mise en compétition à la
libérale des territoires mortifères pour
les communes la réforme des collectivité
territoriale de 2010 que pourtant toute
la gauche avait combattu a été ni abrogé
ni détricoté par votre gouvernement seul
le conseiller territorial qui remplaçait
les conseillers généraux et régionaux a
été supprimé par l'adoption d'une PPL
déposée par notre groupe au Sénat
réformer nos territoires pour réformer
la France voilà la formule utilisée par
le Président de la République pour
justifier sa politique territoriale qui
remet en cause l'architecture
institutionnelle de notre pays cette
réforme territoriale vise trois
objectifs imposer l'austérité attiser la
concurrence entre les territoires et
ouvrir de nouveaux espaces de profit
pour les marché tout en détruisant la
démocratie locale précipiter cette
réforme qui plusé sans consulter le
peuple et le symptôme de la poursuite
des attaques portées contre la
République dénotant un vrai mépris pour
la démocratie et la souveraineté
populaire en se pliant à la seule
volonté de la Commission européenne dont
l'ambition est de diss
en promouvant les régions le cadre
national pour faciliter la circulation
des capitaux et des travailleurs sans
droit cindé en plusieurs textes cette
réforme est devenue illisible quoiquen
dis certain pour nos concitoyens comment
peuvent-ils s'y retrouver quand les élus
locaux eux-mêmes s'y perdent en fait
elles s'attaquent aux deux collectivités
les plus proches des citoyens celles qui
sont à leur côté dans leur difficultés
cela ne peut donc que renforcer la crise
politique et donc engendrer une remise
en cause de la cohésion sociale
répondant aux attentes de la Commission
européenne et du top secret Comité des
Régions la suppression des départements
et la réorganisation libérale du
territoire marque la volonté de réduire
à son maximum l'expression de la
souveraineté populaire en ce sens
l'adaptation du territoire au
libéralisme sacrifie les structures
démocratiques pour mieux s'éloigner de
l'intérêt général par ailleurs ce projet
porte une conception recentrée sur ces
missions une conception de l'État
recentré sur ces missions régaliennes t
qu'elle est promue par les idéologues du
libéralisme et leur traités européens
afin de réduire les dépenses publiques
cet aménagement du territoire entraînera
nécessairement une mise en concurrence
internationale européenne et national
des territoires elle aura pour
conséquence prévisible d'approfondir le
le fossé entre les les régions à fort
potentiel économique et les autres les
régions riches ne vont certainement pas
tirer les régions les plus pauvres elles
vont en réalité être un véritable trou
noir qui aspirera l'essentiel des
richesses cette concurrence induira un
déséquilibre territorial une hiérarchie
inévitable et laissera encore davantage
les plus démunis au bord de la route
mettre en concurrence des territoires
participe du démantelllement des
services publics garant du principe
d'égalité de ce point de vue ce qui nous
sépare profondément c'est notre
attachement au principe républicain
d'unicité des services publics or cette
cette réforme porte dans ces fondements
même l'éclatement de l'égalité
républicaine cette mise en concurrence a
d'ailleurs été poussé à son paroxisme
avec la création des métropoles C ces
dernières dans un objectif de
concentration et d'optimisation
économique crée de grands centres
économiques adaptés au marché et met à
la disposition des multinationales et du
marché capitaliste un espace dans lequel
il va pouvoir trouver tout ce dont il a
besoin pour satisfaire ses appétits en
clair tout est fait pour mettre les
institutions au service des dogmes de
rentabilité de
compétitivité nous n'acceptons pas
monsieur le Premier ministre que votre
gouvernement qui tient légitimité du
peuple de gauche avance et répète comme
un vieux disque rayé ce fameux argument
de la réduction des dépenses publiques
le regroupement et la mutualisation
permettrai selon vous de faire des
économies sans licenciement tout en
améliorant les prestations à la
population alors je dois dire que qui à
part vous et vos amis bien évidemment
peut sincèrement soutenir cette thèse
beaucoup considèrent
aujourd'hui y compris des agences de
notation c'est un comble donc beaucoup
considèrent que les frais de
regroupement des organisations nouvelles
vont coûter plus cher pendant 5 à 10 ans
ce ne sont pas les frais de structure ni
les fonctions support qui coûtent le
plus dans nos collectivités
territoriales mais les services mis en
place en faveur de la population il n'y
aura il y aura il n'y aura réduction des
coûts qu'au prix bien évidemment d'une
d'une réduction brutale des services ce
qui est bien l'objectif inavoué de cette
réforme si les collectivités dépensent
pour se réorganiser et que dans le même
temps les dotations de l'État baisse
alors les collectivités devront réduire
leurs actions en direction de la
population ainsi que leurs
investissements mais ce mouvement est
déjà à l'œuvre et l'austérité gagnera
toujours plus l'action locale comment
pouvez-vous ignorer monsieur le ministre
à ce point la colère qui monte chez les
élus chez les fonctionnaires chez nos
concitoyens face à la réduction des des
dotations au collectivités cet
après-midi même de nombreux maires
ruraux sont venus dire cette colère
devant le Sénat monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Premier ministre votre
vision de la démocratie de
l'organisation des institutions et du
territoire enfin notre vision de la
démocratie plutôt n'est ni archaïque ni
dépassé c'est la politique du
gouvernement qui n'est nullement tournée
vers l'avenire et qui s'inspire des
vieux préceptes libéraux à peine
dépoussiérés des économies min des 18e
et des 19e siècles David Ricardo et Adam
S c'est votre politique qui ramène vers
le passé notre pays retour sur les
acquis sociaux au travers du PLFSS pour
2015 destruction organisée des services
publics culpabilisation des chômeurs
atteinte aux droits des salariés coup
donnés aux fonctionnaires
recentralisation des pouvoirs et
éloignement des centres de décision des
citoyens et j'en passe souscouvert de
modernité c'est en réalité un recul
démocratique MAJ qui est en cours non
monsieur le Premier ministre pour rendre
vos propos vos termes dans une interview
accordé un hebdomadaire qui a changé de
nom nous ne choisissons pas comme vous
le dites de défendre les solutions
d'hier plutôt que de résoudre les
problèmes d'aujourd'hui nous sommes des
partisans déterminés du progrès et le
progrès selon nous c'est placer l'humain
au cœur des décisions et non la logique
financière et comptable comme vous le
faites vous nous sommes
favorable à une évolution des structures
locales encore faut-il analyser les
forces et les faiblesses de ce qui
existe aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi nous
proposons dans le respect des structures
démocratiques existances de remettre à
plat notre organisation territoriale
accompagné d'une réforme
fiscale renforçant vous savez cette
fameuse réforme fiscale dont nous avons
longtemps entendu parler puis qui a été
enterré donc accompagné d'une réforme
fiscale renforçant la libre
administration des collectivité et les
outils de péréquation sur la base de
quatre axes cardinaux démocratie
proximité coopération service public
nous sommes pour une profonde rénovation
de nos institutions rénovation tournée
vers le partage et non la domination des
unes sur des autres dès lors que ce sont
les objectifs de service public et
d'épanouissement humain qui priment nous
sommes Monsieur le Premier Ministre
favorables à des regroupements de
territoires dès lors également qu'ils se
font sur la base de projets convergents
respectueux de l'unicité de la
République quant à l'état nous voulons
qu'il s'investisse dans de grands
projets structurants utiles développeurs
de solutions publiques créateurs
d'emploi et qu'il joue son rôle à son
échelle dans un certain nombre de
domaines santé transport éducation
énergie culture environnement et cetera
oui nous sommes Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pour une 6e république
démocratique et sociale et je dois vous
dire que nous sommes courageux nous
n'avons pas peur et vous le savez bien
de changer radicalement nos institutions
à condition qu'elles apportent plus de
démocratie je pense à l'Assemblée
constituante plus d'implication
citoyennees je pense au contrôle citoyen
par un droit de reg regard sur les
prises de décisions et par plus de
coopération Monsieur le Premier Ministre
votre réforme celle du président n'est
pas majoritaire chez les élus et dans le
pays elle est même à l'origine de fissur
au sein de votre majorité elle doit
faire l'objet d'un référendum populaire
car le peuple ne peut être mis devant le
fait accomplli d'une telle modification
des règles démocratiques contrairement
aux idées reçues nos concitoyens sont
très attachés à leur collectivité dont
leur département y compris en milieu
urbain comme en témoignent les 32000
signatures recueillliis dans le Val de
Marne que mon ami Christian Favier
sénateur et président du conseil général
va vous remettre aujourd'hui oui
Monsieur le Premier Ministre l'heure est
au choix entre les valeurs d'avenir de
progrès et de justice sociale de gauche
en résumé de cette gauche dont la raison
d'être est la contestation de la
toutepuissance du capitalisme et celle
d'un libéralisme passéiste arquebouté
sur ces privilèges dont vous semblez
malheureusement vous faire aujourd'hui
le
porte-parole voilà pour cette
déclaration de manuel Vals qui date du
mois d'octobre déclaration essentielle
dans la réforme territoriale
puisque'alors et bien manuel Vals avait
annoncé le maintien du département il
l'avait annoncé juste avant l'examen en
deuxème lecture par le Sénat du projet
de loi de délimitation de région ce
fameux texte qui a également suscité la
colère des élus qui crée 13 super
régions à la place de nos 22 régions
métropolitaines actuelles 13 régions qui
existeront à partir du mois de janvier
2016 vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les séances sur notre site
publsena.fr très bonne journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaires